bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france alors on a vu
cette la situation en biélorussie et en
ce moment assez tendue entre les pro et
les anti loukachenko comment est ce que
vous vous expliquer cet embrasement
civique
ouais ça fait très longtemps qu'il ya
une opposition assez puissante à
loukachenko
installé dans la vie intellectuelle et
toute la classe moyenne éduquée
en revanche ces campagnes elles étaient
plutôt pro l'occassion cours et les
villes les usines étaient provocation
cet équilibre c'est évidemment aiguisé
si je puis lille et prenait beaucoup
plus instable avec des élections ou
loukachenko contre l'évidence a fait 80
% des voix et que tout le monde a
considéré me semble juste titre que les
élections avaient été avait été truqué
donc maintenant on est un peu dans une
sorte d'impasse puisque le goulot cash
and co haddock un danger extérieur qui
manifestement elle n'existe pas et de là
l'opposition les manifestants qui jusque
du tout anti russe et qui ne le sont pas
mais quand même tirer nos skyhigh
réfugiés en lituanie elle va rencontrer
le secrétaire d'état américain
les français les allemands dans la voix
elle est écoutée en europe toutes les
deux très très prudents jusqu'à présent
et tout le monde considère en tout cas
en europe que les russes doivent jouer
un rôle important
il avait deux enfants l'opposante
sveltana chicanos sky a déclaré que le
président n'avait pas d'autre choix
finalement que d'engager un dialogue
avec l'opposition ce que vous pensez qu
alexandre loukachenko pourrait
l'envisager
alors je pense que tu n as qu il a
raison
sinon si on veut trouver une formule il
faut que lukashenko engagent un dialogue
avec l'opposition alors quand à savoir
si mentalement structurellement il est
capable de le faire ça on peut
s'interroger et c'est là que je pense le
le l'allié russe peut jouer un rôle en
essayant de mettre sur les rails un
dialogue avec l'opposition
loukachenko a également demandé à
l'armée de prendre des mesures plus
strictes selon vous jusqu'où pourrait-il
allait pas bien loin parce que la
biélorusse n'est pas là j'avais déjà la
plus performante de toute la région et
je crois que c'est une posture une
posture politique pour dire vous avez
besoin de moi regardez nous sommes
menacés à nos frontières
tous les artifices sont bons pour
démontrer son sa nécessité et puisqu'il
avait avec d'affaires des deux
mercenaires de wagner un bouquet même
l'argument contre la russie avant son
élection le président loukachenko peut
aussi compter sur ses partisans à quel
point cette situation elle divise le
pays finalement elles vivent ils le pays
en ce sens que toute la partie dynamique
du pays est manifestement soit le départ
de luca chez troc il ya une base les
fonctionnaires les kolkhozes a laissé
plus les kolkhozes bourse à néant les
fermes les agriculteurs qui restent
fidèles
mais je ne pense pas je me trompe
peut-être parce que les sondages ne sont
pas fiables et il n'y en a pas eu
beaucoup mais je ne pense pas qu'il veut
la majorité donc on devra encore une
fois je crois que si on ne veut pas que
la situation qui est gérable
actuellement ne s'aggrave en un nouveau
cas l'ukrainien si on peut dire il faut
très rapidement qu'on arrivait un
compromis entre lukashenko et
l'opposition
loukachenko est au pouvoir depuis 26 ans
il est
on voit depuis depuis deux semaines la
grogne populaire ne fait que s'amplifier
dans les rues de minsk et même dans tout
le pays d'ailleurs peut-il résister
selon vous à la pression populaire où
finalement il va pouvoir rester au
pouvoir à moyen ou à long terme selon
vos puisqu'il semble assez déterminé en
tout cas alors c'est très difficile à
dire mais ce qui est clair c'est que
s'il recourt à un
pour l'instant la dépression à rester
dans les normes
elle a été terrible mais elle est restée
dans des normes
je ne dis pas acceptable enfin que l'on
peut considérer comme n'ayant pas
recours aux extrêmes mais s'ils
commencent à tirer sur la foule a mené
une répression de grande ampleur avec
des morts des prisonniers des disparus
d'un bond il détruit son propre pays
il reste au pouvoir refermer sur un
champ de ruines justement à dernière
question le coaching on refuse toute
médiation européenne qu'il qualifie
comme une interférence extérieure et il
a plutôt il a depuis séduit tant
exprimés par rapport avec avec la russie
néanmoins est ce que sur le long terme
c'est jouable pour lui aussi qu'il va
devoir rester campé sur ses positions
alors les offres des actions extérieures
sont relativement intéresser bon la
pologne autrefois le laquelle russie
était polono lituanienne comme chacun
sait donc la partie pro russe se méfie
un peu de ce genre de pau les rues
semaine les russes ont effectivement on
peut passer de la biélorussie posséder
la biélorussie depuis le partage la
pologne
donc tout le monde de tourner étaient
intéressés à faire avancer ses pions
donc le compromis n'en est que plus plus
nécessaire pour éviter une dégradation
de la situation est à nouveau un
affrontement que personne ne soit
actuellement et c'est intéressant mais
un affrontement entre la russie et les
pays occidentaux
merci à jean de gliniasty d'avoir
répondu à la question je rappelle que
vous êtes
hector et de recherche à l'iris et
ancien ambassadeur de france à moscou
merci à vous